algunas caras conocidas otras menos los
líderes de la coalición de derechas
italiana celebraron el jueves su último
mitin electoral Georgia meloni del
partido de extrema derecha hermanos de
Italia aspira a convertirse en la
próxima primera ministra del país
construiremos Un gobierno Sólido y
cohesionado Con un fuerte mandato
popular que permanecerá en el poder
durante cinco años le guste o no a la
izquierda
a la siniestra
una pieza bien a una escuadra unita un
programa con una alianza unida un
programa compartido un destino común y
un compromiso un compromiso que asumo yo
que ASUME Georgia Silvio Mauricio
gobernar bien y juntos durante cinco
años
gobernar Bene e incienme perchincue acné
la coalición del Primer Ministro
saliente Mario tragui se derrumbó a
principios de año melón y fue la única
líder de un partido principal que no se
unió a su coalición en 2021 y su partido
lidera ahora las encuestas lo lanzó en
2012 y su popularidad no ha hecho más
que crecer
tiene sus raíces en un movimiento
posfacista fundado por partidarios de
Mussolini un 40% de los italianos sigue
indeciso o ha dicho que no votará en un
país que ha tenido casi 70 gobiernos
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial todavía
espacio para la sorpresa